let me outline on four different
possible explanations one can give and
and I will just leave it leave it to the
audience to reflect on on these four
possible explanations for why we've had
this extraordinary run of bubbles and
busts over the last number of decades
the first one which one might describe
is sort of the the left-wing or liberal
answer is that it has it has basically
been driven by reckless lending lack of
regulation and greed and that and that
in effect of the entire boom since the
early Reagan years in 1982 was basically
driven by by by this escalating leverage
that in effect was more fake than real
and and that it has basically come to an
end and that it worked what it did but
it was basically the fault of the of the
lenders and all kinds of agency problems
associated with them there's a there's a
second type of political ants which is
the right-wing or conservative answer
which is that it basically was the fault
of the borrowers that they were
recklessly borrowing all this money and
it was it was people who were too greedy
in buying houses and going on credit and
and that it was sort of the product of a
narcissistic and selfish generation that
was not was short-sighted and not
thinking about the future and under that
sort of a narrative you might trace
things back to say 1968 and say that was
the year that everything went downhill
in the US and the hippies took over or
something something along those lines
now I think there's it is of course the
case these two explanations are not
inconsistent and it is possible that
there were problems with both the
lenders and the borrowers and that in
some sense there was something about
something deeper about the whole
political system which failed to
proactively deal with these things and
just speaking up speaking on my own
context
you know it was obvious that there was
an insane housing bubble three years ago
and you could talk about it you could
scream about it you could go on CNBC and
tell people there was a housing bubble
they should not buy houses and it was
like shouting into a hurricane nobody
was willing to listen and and there is
something about the nature of these
things that is extraordinarily a
procyclical in a bad way in terms of our
political system where when there is
when there is when everything's going
well the regulations get loosened when
things are going badly they get
tightened so that in effect the
political process has had the effect not
of dampening these bubbles and booms but
actually exacerbating them tremendously
and I think that is going to be one of
the real serious challenges we face in
the years ahead in the technology
context for example in the late 90s out
which you know they were obviously
tremendous abuses we dealt with the
abuses with sarbanes-oxley and they've
been basically no more AI tech IPOs or
virtually no tech IPOs in six years so
we had we had an excessive boom the
regulators did nothing and then we had
an excessive bust and we had an
overreaction and and again you can blame
it on special interest groups that are
serving the lenders you can blame it on
on on the desire of the borrowers to
keep the easy money going
but when basically both of them end you
have to wonder how how this how this can
better be handled I think one of the
challenges the that is happening on a
global scale is that the inability of
our political system to proactively deal
with these bubbles is calling into
question the very concept of democratic
capitalism and I think one of the one of
the challenges in the next next four to
five years is that a sort of a more
authoritarian version of capitalism of
the sort that one sees in China will get
a lot more appeal because the argument
will be that it is able to to resist the
the appeal of people and special
interest groups and sort of act on
behalf of the whole society and I think
the challenge for the next president is
going to be to somehow rehabilitate of
the good name of democratic capitalism
and it will be Italy quite a big
challenge and I certainly hope that
whoever becomes president will succeed
at that
let me let me however outline a fourth
possible explanation for why so many of
these bubbles have turned into busts and
this is probably my own my own personal
hobbyhorse honest which is that there's
not been enough real growth in the
economy and that in some sense the
reason so many of these booms didn't
work was that the whole economy was not
growing and this is not a question about
finance or politics or regulation or at
least not centrally about those but
about science and technology and the
rate at which science and technology are
progressing and and I think sort of won
and you know while there's incredible
hype surrounding tech companies and
scientific innovation the reality has
simply not lived up to the hype for a
very long time and and the the you know
the anecdote I would cite is if we were
sitting in this room in 1968 and talking
about what was the future of the u.s.
going to look like in 40 years you know
we would have predicted vacation trips
to the moon spaceships on Mars massive
increases in productivity ZURB on
schreiber european writer wrote the
american challenge in 1967 said that by
the year 2000 the average person in the
US would be working seven hours a day
four days a week and have 13 weeks a
year of paid vacation time which which
was a reflection of the incredible
growth in productivity that was set to
take place by accelerating technology
and science and I and it's gone
everything's gone the other way there's
not been enough progress and I think I
think the long-term challenge that I
would submit is that we somehow need to
to get that restarted and it is very
it's not easy it's it's broken down for
a lot of very complicated reasons but I
think that that in some sense on that's
the kind of thing that it needs to be
very much we started if I had a last
thought on this is if one had to look at
the whole series of bubbles the one that
I think was the central one perhaps not
just in time but also in importance was
the tech bubble of the late 90s and in
some sense when that one turned out to
go wrong it meant that none of them
would work because if there was not
going to be exponential progress in
technology enough
else made sense and you could leverage
up in housing but eventually housing
prices would go down if there was no
real growth in the society taking place
and the same I think is true of Finance
and to a lesser extent of the the
emerging market of the emerging market
story so I think the I would encourage
us to very seriously rethink why there's
been so little progress and how that can
be accelerate and I think this is
certainly one of the great things that a
big thing is an impetus for doing